ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ครับนักเรียนนะคะก็กลับมาเจอกับครูหญิง
มันก็ครูฟ้านะคะอีกหนึ่งอีกแล้วถูกต้องใน
ชั่วโมงงงบีกินเนอร์นะคะร้านมีฟ้าคะวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะมีข้อ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้นี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 3 เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตต
2565  a  Call ศ.
2022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 5
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้ว
คะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 18:00
06:00 นใช่ไหมคะหกโมงเช้าอีกกี่นาทีคะ
สามสิบห้านาที
35 นาที
ครูฟ้าตอนนี้เนี่ย 06:00 นเป็นเวลาเช้า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นหรือยังครูฟ้ายังไม่ตื่น
ง่วง
ทรายเข้าใจค่ะครูหญิงเนี่ยเห็นหน้าครูฟ้า
ก็คิด
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่น
100% ไหม
ใช่ก็คิดคิดคิด
ๆแล้วครูฟ้าก็ออกยังไม่ตื่นเลยฟ้า
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะเดี๋ยวครูหญิงมีเกมให้ครูฟ้า
เล่นครูฟ้าจะได้ตื่น 100%
นะครับครูฟ้าเกมอะไรเหรอคะครูหญิงเอ้าครู
หญิงก็จะมีคำถามมีคำถาม
มีคำถามที่คำถามเนี่ยนะคะครูหญิงก็จะมี
รูปมีรูปค่ะจนเป็นรูปวัด
รูปรูปอะไรเนี่ยนะคะมีรูปให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ดูนะครูฟ้าดูแล้วครูฟ้าก็คิดว่าสถานที่ใน
รูปเนี่ยอยู่ประเทศอะไรวิ่งก็จะมี Choice
นะคะฟ้า
EB เอา 1 กับ 2 ดีกว่าน้องจะได้เป็นภาษา
ไทย
มี Choice  1 แล้วก็จะมีประเทศ 2 แล้วก็
ประเทศครูฟ้าต้องคิดว่ารูปเนี้ยอยู่
ประเทศมีอะไหล่เอา
มันเช็คเวอร์บลูฟ้าจะรู้จักประเทศนัก
เรียนไหมไม่ใช่อยู่ในประเทศไทยนะ
ไม่มีประเทศไทยไม่รู้แล้วแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ต้องคิดรูปนี้อยู่ในประเทศอยู่ที่ประเทศ
อะไร
นะว่าผู้หญิงได้เลยโรงไฟ้าพร้อมไหมคะ
พร้อมกันหอมพร้อมเราก็ไปดูรูปแรกเลยค่ะ
ได้ค่ะอ่ะเนื้อหาอุ่นเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงขอขยาย
ครูฟ้ากับครูหญิงก่อนนะคะจะได้ใหญ่ๆ
เออ
ครูฟ้าเห็นหรือยังคะ
เห็นแล้วค่ะรูปนี้เนี่ย
คืออะไรนะทรายรูปนี้นะคะครูฟ้าน่า
เขาเรียกว่าเออ
โคลอสเซี่ยมนะคนละเซีย
[เพลง]
รู้ฟ้าเนี่ย
เห็นซักคนละเสียบดูรูปแล้วนะคะคล้ายๆเป็น
Stadium เนาะสนามกีฬาเหมือนตอนนี้เราก็
ดูฟุตบอลวอลเลย์บอลใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าคะรูป
นี้นะคะโคลอสเซี่ยมเนี่ยอยู่ที่ประเทศ
อะไรนะคะอ่ะ 1
ทั่วประเทศอิตาลี
[ปรบมือ]
2 ประเทศโปรตุเกส
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าอยู่ที่ประเทศอะไร
รูปฟ้าคิดว่า
อยู่ที่ประเทศ
อิตาลีค่ะสลีย์ RE ฟ้า
มั่นใจนะคะชัวร์ไหมน่ากลัวไหมกูฟ้า
ช่วยสวด
ครูฟ้าบอกว่ารูปนี้นะคะโคลอสเซียมเนี่ย
อยู่ที่ที่ร้านเทศอิตาลี
จริงๆแท้ๆนั้นเธอ
โคคาถ้า
ไม่ต้องเยอะดังมากสูงตัดเสียงเย้ๆอาเย้
ตัดเหรอยังตัดสินใจขอดูฟ้า
เซ็งนะคะใจหักอิตาลีนะคะต่อใช้แล้ว
ไม่ต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้า
รู้ให้ในรูปนี้ครูฟ้าเห็นอะไรบ้างเห็นภู
เขา
ภูเขาภูเขาภูเขาภูเขาอ่าแล้วก็เห็นพี่ไหม
ครูฟ้า
กำแพงต่ายค่ะอ่ะสถานที่ในรูปนะคะอุ๊ยเค้า
พูดชื่อครูฝาก็ต้องรู้จักใช่ไหมไม่พูดไม่
เอาดีกว่าเกมก็คือไม่พูดให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยดู
รูปเรื่องดอกนะอ่าอ่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยดูรูป
เนื้อหาในรูปนี้มีภูเขามีกำแพงค่ะ
สถานที่ในรูปนี้อยู่ที่ประเทศอะไร
สถานที่นี้
อยู่ที่ประเทศ
หนึ่งประเทศเนปาลมือ
สองประเทศจีน
คิดว่าอยู่ที่ประเทศอะไรคะ
คิดว่าสถานที่นี้
อยู่ที่ประเทศจีนค่ะ
ประเทศจีนชัวร์ไหมหัวไหม
ตัว
ถูกค่ะเย้
เนื้อเพลงพอ
grill  by
groupon เนี่ยตอบถูกใช่ไหมคะอยู่ที่
ประเทศจีนแล้วครูฟ้ารู้ไหมสถานที่นี้ชื่อ
ว่าอะไร
ภาษาไทยบอกว่า
กำแพงเมืองจีนค่ะใช่ค่ะกำแพงเมืองจีนใช่
ไหมคะโว่
ยางเอามากๆ
ไม่รู้
กี่กิโลเมตรนะคะเอ้ยอันนี้กิโลกรัมอ่ะ
กิโลกรัม
กิโลกรัมกี่กิโลเมตรเนาะไม่รู้นะแต่ครู
ฟ้าเก่งมากเย้
ลูกต่อไปค่ะมีค่ะสถานที่นี้นะคะ
ครูฟ้าดูรูปเนาะแล้วฟ้าแน่คิดว่าสถานที่
ตอนนี้อยู่ที่ประเทศอะไร
หนึ่งประเทศอียิปต์ 5
2 ประเทศโมรอคโค
หน้า
สถานที่นี้อยู่ที่ประเทศ
อียิปต์ a ดิบแน่ใจไหมคะเปลี่ยนใจไหมแน่
ใจอ่ะแม่ใส่ก็ได้
โอเค
ถูกฆ่าอิอิ
อีเอ
ครูฟ้า groupon เนี่ยตอบถูกในรูปเราเรียก
ว่าอะไรคะ
ธีระมิตรค่ะ
Pyramid นอนในรูปนี้เนี่ยชื่อว่า
พีระมิดกีซ่าหนอนอยู่ในทั่วประเทศกินซ่า
ขอโทษนะกินซ่าไว้อยู่ในประเทศอียิปต์นั้น
เองก็เขาเป็นหมอได้นะคะ
เฮียอามิค่ะต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้าฟังเก่งมากเลย
อ่ะ
รูปต่อไปนะคะนี่น้องมี
มีแม่น้ำหรือทะเล
สมัยมีสะพานแล้วก็มีอันนี้นะคะสุวรรณภูมิ
หรือเปล่าคะนะคะเรือหรือเปล่า
สถานที่นี้อยู่ที่ประเทศอะไร
ออสเตรเลีย
นิวซีแลนด์
สถานที่นี้อยู่ที่ประเทศประเทศอะไรอ่ะ
เดรสเตเลียค่ะบอกว่าออสเตรเลีย
ถูกมั้ย
ถูกค่ะค่ายเอ
รูฟ้าตอบถูกครูฟ้า Fruit ไหมสถานที่นี้
ชื่อว่าอะไร
เวลาเฮ้าส์มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะคนไทยพูดเนาะ Opera
House นะครูฟ้า
ไปไหมว่าอยากไปมาก
ๆให้อย่าไป Opera  House นะคะ
ต่อไปค่ะรูปต่อไป
ครูฟ้าน่าดูแล้วเนาะในรูปเนี่ยก็น่าจะมี
เหมือนหินนะคะแล้วก็ตรงนี้เนี่ยเป็นสนาม
หญ้านะคะสนามหญ้า
สถานที่นี้มีที่อยู่ที่ประเทศอะไร
งั้น
อ้ะ
131 สกอตแลนด์ค่ะ
2 อังกฤษ
สกอตแลนด์หรืออังกฤษ
ประเทศอะไรนะ
บอกว่าเอาประเทศยืนอาหาร
สถานที่นี้อยู่ที่ประเทศ
United  States
อังกฤษค่ะครูบาตอบ 2 ใช่ไหมอังกฤษ
ขู่ฆ่า
เก่งมากครูฟ้าตอบถูกแล้วครูฟังรู้ไหมคะ
ว่าขอฝันที่นี้ชื่ออะไรจำไม่ได้ค่ะแต่กู
ฟ้ารู้ใช่ไหมเห็นแล้วรู้ให้หาจะจำไม่ได้
เหมือนคนละเสี้ยมอ่ะถ้ากูพาฟังเนี่ยก็รู้
แต่จำไม่ได้นะฮะ
ครูบาจำไม่ได้ใช่ไหมชื่ออะไรให้ค่ะครู
หญิง
มันชื่อว่าโดนเห็น
สุโคเนตนี่สาย Stone เห็นเนาะอยู่ที่
ประเทศอังกฤษนะคะสถานที่ต่อไปค่ะถ้าน่าจะ
ไม่ยากน้องเป็นผู้หญิงเหรอคะในรูปเนี้ย
ผู้หญิงค่ะคุยมือ
ขวาถือถึง
ไอศครีม
คุณผู้สวยครูเอ๋เลยเอ๋ค่าห้องเหมือน
ไอศกรีมไม่ช่วยไอศครีม Records เพลิงแล้ว
ก็มือซ้ายนะคะน่าจะซื้อหนังสือหรือว่า
สมุดนะค่ะสถานที่ในรูปนี้หรือว่านี้เรา
เรียกว่า
รูปปั้นหรอรูปปั้นรูปปั้นนี้นะคะอยู่ที่
ประเทศอะไร
สหรัฐอเมริกาสหรัฐอเมริกา
ประเทศแคนาดา
ประเทศแคนาดาประเทศสหรัฐอเมริกาหรือว่า
ประเทศแคนาดาครูฟ้า
ตอบอะไรคะ
สถานที่นี้อยู่ที่ประเทศ
สหรัฐอเมริกาค่ะนี่คิดถึงเนาะสหรัฐ
อเมริกาหรือว่าคนไทยพูดสั้นๆประเทศอะไรคะ
อเมริกา
อเมริกาน้องฟ้าต่ออเมริกานาฬิกา
[เพลง]
มีอะไรคะเนี่ยวิธีทำอะไรอ่ะ
กูฆ่า
เก่งมากครูฟ้าแล้วครูบารู้ไหมว่ารูปปั้น
นะรูปปั้นอะนี้เนี่ยชื่อไหร่หน้าสิ
ซื้ออะไร
เทพี
เสรีภาพไหม
ใช่ค่ะเทพีเสรีภาพแล้วอยู่ที่ประเทศ
อเมริกาอยู่ไหนในอเมริกา
ยอด
นิวยอร์ก
นิวยอร์กต่อไปค่ะต่อไปค่ะโหสวยไหมคะครู
ฟ้า
ประเทศอะไรคะนี่สถานที่นี้อยู่อยู่ที่
ประเทศอะไรนะคะ
1 ไฮ่ 2
เมียนมาร์หรือพม่าพม่า
ใช่หรือพม่าหรือว่า Myanmar เนาะ
ทหารที่นี้อยู่ที่ประเทศ
พม่าค่ะครูฟ้าตอบ 2 พม่า
10 ชาติ
ผิดค่ะ
ไม่ได้อยู่ที่ประเทศถามว่ากูฟ้าอยู่ที่
ประเทศไทย
งูประเทศให้แล้วเนี่ยอยู่ที่ภูเขานะคะ
ชื่อดอยอินทนนท์น้อยอยู่มีคนบนดอย
อินทนนท์สวยมากว่าเคยไปอ่ะเป็นอันๆใดไฟ
ฟ้าทำไมตอบผิดค่ะ
ก็เคยไปแล้ว
ชื่ออะไรนะ
อันนี้มันเป็นของในหลวงเนาะผู้หญิงไม่แน่
ใจว่าเจดีย์นะเจดีย์เนี่ยมันจะเป็นของ
ในหลวงภูมิพลนะคะคิงภูมิพลแล้วก็นี้ของ
คุยนะคะแต่พี่ไม่แน่ใจเนาะ
อันนี้ของคิงหรือว่านี้ของควีนไม่แน่ใจนะ
คะอ่าอ่อนรู้สึกว่าอันอันนี้ของคิงอัน
ข้างในของควีนจากมีชี้ถูกเนาะอะไรนะคะของ
คุยของคิงคิงภูมิพลนะนี่คุยสิริกิติ์นะคะ
เก่งมากค่ะครูฟ้าคะเก่งอะไรคะต่อไปค่ะโห
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าสถานที่ในรูปตอนนี้อยู่ที่
ประเทศอะไร
โอเคหนึ่งประเทศโปรแลนด์
2 ประเทศ
ฝรั่งเศสน่าจะไม่ยากนะฟ้า
1 หรือ 2 คะทหารที่มีนี้นะคะอยู่ที่
ประเทศ
ฝรั่งเศสฝรั่งเศสนะ 2 ขู่ฆ่า
[เพลง]
แล้วครูฟ้ารู้ไหมสถานที่นิดชื่อว่าอะไร
กำแพงเมืองฝรั่งเศส
เค้าชื่อว่าประตูใช้น้องประก้นไทยพูดราสุ
ชัยแต่ภาษาฝรั่งเศสเนี่ยครูหญิงออกเสียง
ไม่ได้นะคะแบบคนไทยอาจจะอุด Charge  The
พร้อมนะคะประตูชัยแต่ละคนฝรั่งเศสแต่ไม่
ใช่อะไรเพียงเพศนะฮะคนไทยเรียกประตูชัย
เนาะอ่ะเก่งมากค่ะต่อไปค่ะวันนี้น่าจะไม่
ยากนะคะอ่ะครูฟ้าสถานที่นี้นะคะในรูปนี้
อยู่ที่ประเทศอะไร
หนึ่งประเทศญี่ปุ่น
ต่อสองประเทศเกาหลีใต้นะคะตาเป็นไงคน
อย่างเขา
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าอยู่ที่ประเทศอะไร
รูปฟ้าคิดว่า
สถานที่นี้อยู่ที่ประเทศ
ญี่ปุ่นค่ะหนึ่งเนาะญี่ปุ่นนะคะ
ถูกค่ะพี่
ตัวเองแล้วครูฟ้ารู้ไหมว่ามันสถานที่นี้
ชื่อว่าอะไร
เนี่ยอันนี้นี่ภูเขาไฟ
ฟูจิชัยสาภูเขาไฟฟูจิน้อยอยู่ที่ประเทศ
ญี่ปุ่นนะคะต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้าไม่นี้คืออะไร
กันเนี่ย
เมื่อไหร่
สถานที่นี้นะคะอยู่ที่ประเทศอะไรเนาะ
หนังหนึ่งประเทศกัมพูชา
2 ประเทศ
อินโดนีเซีย
สถานที่นี้อยู่ที่ประเทศ
กัมพูชาค่ะ 1 นะกัมพูชาถูกค่ะค่ะหูฝาเก่ง
มากอ่ะอ่ะ
ดีแล้วครูฟ้ารู้ไหมว่าสถานที่นี้ชื่ออะไร
นะกินพนม
นครพนมอยู่ที่ประเทศไทยค่ะ
ณห้อนุวัฒน์ชายนครวัดนะคะแต่นักเรียนอาจ
จะรู้จักในชื่ออังกอร์วัดหนองแต่คนไทย
เนี่ยพูดนครวัดน่ะนครวัด
อีก 1 รูปค่ะครูฟ้าหมดเวลาแล้วแต่อีก 1
รูปนะวิ่งหนีอีก 1 รูปนะคะไม่สุดท้ายนะคะ
ครูฟ้าสถานที่นี้อยู่ที่ประเทศอะไร
หนึ่งประเทศศรีลังกา
ประเทศอินเดียอยู่ที่ประเทศอะไรคะ
สถานที่นี้อยู่ที่ประเทศ
เอ่ออินเดียค่ะอินเดียหูยิ่งว่า
ถูกค่ะแล้วครูฟ้ารู้ไหมมันชื่อว่าอะไร
สถานที่นี้
ก็ไทยบอกว่าสัมผัสหัวใจ
คลาส More  All ตายทัชมาฮาลหนอเป็นคนไหน
ว่าเป็นที่ที่เป็นเกี่ยวกับความรักน้อง
ของผู้ชายนะคะที่สร้างให้ผู้หญิงให้ภรรยา
จะไม่น่าจะไปหา King หรอกของอินเดียเมื่อ
ก่อนเนาะทัชมาฮาลนะคะเกี่ยวกับความรักนะ
คะครูฟ้าเก่งมาก
ปูฟ้ารู้ใช่ไหมว่าหลายๆสถานที่อยู่ที่
ประเทศอะไรนะคะนักเรียนเนี่ยตอบถูกไหมเรา
ต้องก็คิดว่าครูสาเก่งไหมก็คอมเม้นท์บอก
ได้นะคะบอกให้ฟังกินอ้าวคอมเม้นท์บอกได้
ส่วนวันนี้นะเราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ